bienvenidos de nuevo estoy en la sección
número 8 en el examen número 7 y
empezamos una nueva sección y por lo
tanto este es el primer vídeo y entonces
vamos a el problema número uno y el
problema número uno dice lo siguiente
ahora le tengo una ecuación
esta es la ecuación creo que no está tan
difícil de resolver tengo 6.700 esto es
igual a 100 a 100 que multiplica a 6 acá
más 7 y lo que me preguntan es cuánto
vale que ahora lo primero que quiero que
veas es que esta ecuación es una
ecuación de primer grado y además
tenemos a este ciento multiplicando a
esta expresión que tengo aquí ahora
podríamos distribuir la multiplicación
adentro del paréntesis pero creo que es
mucho más fácil de una vez dividir todo
el 300 así que voy a quitar este 100 y
aquí voy a quitar dos ceros voy a
dividir todo el recién y no va a quedar
que el 67 que 67 es igual a cero
+ 7 una vez que ya quite este 100 y
ahora puede restar 7 de ambos lados de
esta ecuación voy a mostrar x 7 ok y de
este lado también voy a hacer lo mismo
de tal manera que estos dos se van a ir
y me va a quedar que 6,6 k es igual a 60
67 menos 760 y ya para finalizar puedo
dividir todo entre 6 me va a quedar que
acá vale 10 de lujo es la respuesta de
este problema acá igual a 10 y estamos
en el inciso c
ok primer problema resuelto vamos el
segundo problema vamos a ver qué me dice
si un número n ha aumentado en 3 es un
número negativo ok
cuando yo tengo a n iv le sumó 3
me da un número negativo un número menor
que cero y después dice por otra parte
cinco más ese mismo número es un número
positivo 5 más ese mismo número es un
número positivo es un número mayor que 0
ok
cuando los siguientes incisos
el valor de n ok bueno se me ocurre que
vamos a ir a través del problema dice n
3 es menor que cero y después cuando
esta expresión es de sumo 2 llegó un
número mayor que 0 cuánto vale
n ok lo que se mejoró es que de aquí
podemos despejar el valor de n de esta
desigualdad no va a decir que n es más
pequeño que menos 3 ok esto es la
primera desigualdad pero es una
desigualdad si yo despejó a gente
también voy a obtener que el cne es más
grande que menos 5 y bueno un número que
está entre al menos tres y menos cinco
se me ocurre uno de un montón sí sí sí
pero el más común o creo que tal vez el
número más fácil de pensar entre estos
dos pues es n igual a menos cuatro unos
4 es el número que está entre estos dos
y además cumple estas dos ecuaciones que
cuando nosotros sumamos 3 me da un
número negativo me dan menos 1 y cuando
yo le sumó 55 menos 4 es 1 y por lo
tanto me da un número positivo y vamos a
ver
es el inciso b y bueno es el inciso b
porque la respuesta más sencilla que os
podemos tomar para el valor de n pero
teniendo también puede valer nose menos
3.5 o lo que sea en fin problema número
2 vamos a resolver el problema número 3
así que lo voy a poner justo por acá
problema número 3 dice si x es igual a
70 y además tengo a unas tres rectas así
tengo una recta por acá ok
una venta por acá ok y otro recta por
acá ok y después de muchos valores de
ángulos tengo el valor de este ángulo
este ángulo se llama x este ángulo se va
se llama 10 y me dicen si x vale 70 es
decir que este ángulo de que está acá
son 70 grados 70 grados y sigue vale 40
vale 40 grados
ok cuánto vale z hoy es que además me
dan unas líneas punteadas me dan la
siguiente línea punteada este de aquí
y es algo más o menos así creé punteada
puntada puntilla de algo zinc y además
me dan otra por aquí nada por aquí por
aquí por aquí por aquí por aquí por aquí
que llega hasta acá ok y me dicen si x
es igual a 70 y que sigua de 40 y las
líneas punteadas me sacan los ángulos x
y james ok si estás viste caen los
ángulos xy quien eso quiere decir que la
cantidad de ángulos que hay de que camps
es exactamente los mismos que la
cantidad de ángulos que de que acá son
los mismos valores pero si se caen
quiere decir que parten a este ángulo x
a la mitad y 70 entre 2 es 35 es decir
que de que acá hay 35 grados y de que
acá también hay 35 grados eso por una
parte pero por otra parte también me
dicen que esta línea y seca al ángulo y
es decir a déjame cambiar de color es
decir que la distancia que hay aquí acá
es la misma la distancia que hay de que
acá por lo tanto este ángulo lo voy a
partir en dos
aquí hay 20 grados y aquí también 20
grados
lo que me preguntan es el valor de z y
no te dado ni siquiera el valor de zeta
así que vamos a ponerlo z es el ángulo
que va de aquí y hasta acá
este es z este z lo podemos ver más
cerca porque este valor de aquí acá es
zeta
esto es z ok si esto se tapó solamente
nos resta sumar 35 más 20 24 55 grados
70 es igual a 55 grados y ya está ya
tengo el valor de z ok lo único que
había que fijarnos es que estas rectas
bis secan al ángulo x disminuyen y por
lo tanto los partes a la mitad muy bien
el problema número 4 dejan de borrar
esto de aquí y voy a trabajar con el
problema número 4 o espera espera
pongamos otra capa rama número 4 dice
una fruta es seleccionada de una manera
aleatoria de una canasta de frutas
la probabilidad de que esa fruta sea una
manzana ok la probabilidad de que sea
manzana déjeme poner con rojo es una
manzana roja la probabilidad de que sea
manzana manzana esto es igual a dos
quintos dos quintos ok lo que me
preguntan es cuál de los siguientes
incisos no puede ser la cantidad de
piezas de fruta que hay en la canasta ok
esto es muy importante si la
probabilidad de que fueran manzanas es
de dos quintos eso quiere decir que si
nosotros tenemos un número total de
frutas
supongamos aunque le llama un número
total dos quintos dos quintos por el
número total por el número total de
frutas que la canasta esto tiene que ser
igual al número de manzanas que la
canasta al número de manzanas que la
canasta
más ok y esto porque te lo pongo porque
si el número total lo vamos a
multiplicar por dos quintos esto es lo
mismo que al número total multiplicarlo
por dos y dividirlo entre 5 ahora lo
importante aquí es que hagas la
reflexión de que no hay medias frutas en
esta canasta que tengo aquí todas las
frutas deben de ser números enteros
porque tengo una manzana o un plátano o
una naranja qué sé yo las frutas que
tenga lo que sí sé es que deben de ser
números enteros porque no podemos tener
un cuarto de naranja o dos tercios de
manzana por lo tanto el número total que
tengo aquí es de aquí debe de ser
divisible en 35 para que obtenga un
número natural fíjate bien si yo tengo
dos quintos y voy a dividir todo
temprano ante cinco para que me dé un
número natural yo necesito que este este
de aquí sea divisible entre 5 y si te
das cuenta por ejemplo mi inciso a es 20
a ver ponga bloque inciso am es 20 eso
quiere decir que las manzanas que hay
a canasta con frutas la cantidad de
manzanas sería veinte por dos quintos y
esto es lo mismo que 40 y 35 lo cual es
8 ok
20 6 división entre 5 y lo que me
preguntan es cuando los siguientes
incisos no puede ser la cantidad de
piezas de fruta que hay en la canasta si
te das cuenta el inciso b es 35 esto
también se cuestiona entre 3 en 612
déjenme cambiar de color el inciso c es
52 52 y justo este es el que no funciona
se iguala 52 por qué porque 52 no es un
número de invisible entre 5 entonces yo
me tomaría dos quintos por 52 esto es
exactamente lo mismo que 104 entre 5 y
este número este de aquí no es un número
entero me quedarían 20 manzanas y cuatro
quintos de manzana y eso no puede ser
ok pero ya está el problema número 4 es
el 10 y 12 52 porque no es
entre 5 vamos en el siguiente problema
volvemos a esto y dice mi problema
número 5 un cuadrado y un triángulo
equilátero tienen
el mismo perímetro problema número 5 un
cuadrado como éste ok y un triángulo
equilátero como éste algo más o menos
así un triángulo parecido a este tienen
el mismo perímetro si el lado del
cuadrado vale 3 cuánto vale el lado del
triángulo el lado espera dejar cambiar
de herramienta el lado del cuadrado vale
3 entonces este vale 3 entonces este
vale 3 y entonces éste vale 3 y de una
vez cuánto vale el perímetro de este
cuadrado pues el perímetro de su
cuadrado es 3 por 4 lo cual es 2 ok de
lugo si el lado del cuadrado vale 3
cuánto vale el lado de este triángulo
fonte vale el lado de este triángulo
ahora date cuenta que este tenemos
desequilibró por lo tanto la suma
a sus lados me tiene que dar lo mismo
que el perímetro de este cuadrado pero
la suma de estos lados y si su lado vale
x sería 3 x 3 x tiene que ser igual a lo
mismo que vale el perímetro de este
cuadrado que es 12 y de aquí ya podemos
despejar la x x debe de ser igual a 2
entre 3 los cuales 44 debe de valer el
lado del triángulo para que tenga el
mismo perímetro que este cuadrado 4 x 4
x 4 aquí y vamos a ver 604 1 4242 del
ojo el problema número 5 es x igual a 4
que por cierto es el inciso c entonces
ya tenemos aquí la respuesta problema
número 6 déjenme borrar esta pantalla
para hacerlo justo aquí el problema
número 6
6 el problema número 6 que dice lo
siguiente dice si x es igual a menos 1 x
es igual a menos 1 ok
ica ica es un número positivo es un
número positivo entonces cuál es los
siguientes sencillos tiene el valor más
grande a ver veamos los incisos me dice
incisión número 1 inciso a dos por cada
x x 2 por cada x x bueno si te das
cuenta como x como x es un número
negativo es menos 12 por k por x me va a
dar un número negativo porque acá es
positivo positivo por positivo es
positivo por un número negativo por
menos 1 me va a dar un número menor que
cero y yo estoy segurísimo que debe de
haber algún número positivo entre mis
respuestas por lo tanto no creo que sea
mi respuesta el inciso am porque tengo
un número negativo y más aún si lo
pensamos un poco quiero que veas que
todas las potencias de x
que sean impares me van a dar números
negativos y todas las potencias que sean
pares me van a dar números positivos por
lo tanto es muy importante tomar una
potencia par para tener un número
positivo fíjate bien por ejemplo el
inciso c el inciso c tengo seis veces
acá por equis kubica pero menos uno al
cubo menos uno el cubo es lo mismo que
menos uno y entonces me quedaría menos
uno por seis acá lo cual es un número
negativo toda potencia impar de x toda
potencia en par de menos uno siempre es
un número negativo de hecho es menos uno
porque menos uno por menos uno por menos
uno me da menos uno ok entonces vamos a
buscar a las potencias bares y las
únicas dos que son pares es el inciso b
el xove que dice 4 k por x al cuadrado y
el inciso de el cis orden que dice 8
por equis a la cuarta ok ahora lo que
quiero que me preguntes o más bien lo
que quiero que me respondas es cuánto
vale x cuadrada bueno pues esto lo mismo
que menos 1 al cuadrado menos 1 al
cuadrado es 1 entonces este valor de
aquí esto es 1 y 1 por 4 que es lo mismo
que cuatro veces acá ok esto es eso ven
ahora cuánto vale menos 1 elevado a la
cuarta potencia bueno pues me quedaría
menos 1 por menos 1 lo cual es 1 por
menos 1 es menos 1 por menos 1 es 1 x
elevada la cuarta potencia también me da
1 también me da 1 por lo tanto 8 carl
por x la cuarta es lo mismo que 8 k de
lujo ahora que es más grande 8 k o 4
camps si sabemos que acá es un número
positivo bueno pues ya tienen la
respuesta así que es un número positivo
es mucho más grande tomarme ocho veces
esa misma cosa que cuatro veces esa
misma cosa por lo tanto mi respuesta es
el inciso de que es 8 por cada x x a la
cuarta porque porque 8 que abbas
que 4k y ya esta es la respuesta de este
problema número 6 y como ya se mejoró el
tiempo nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo
hasta la próxima